J'appartiens aujourd'hui, euh.
Mon parti,
à 1 groupe au Parlement européen, qui est le groupe
CR, qui sera demain
le centre de gravité de la droite, hein,
et qui peut être, euh.
Le faiseur de roi de la nouvelle majorité,
qui aura donc 1 poids
absolument incontournable et décisif
pour pouvoir, euh.
Mettre en place cette robe de la coopération
et du respect des nations
et de la logique de puissance,
ce que j'appelle de mes vœux,
et qui s'opposera bien sûr
tout ce qu'on a évoqué aujourd'hui,
c'est-à-dire le fameux tsunami de normes
lié au pacte vert ou encore la création de nouveaux
impôts européens.
Euh, je serai à ce rendez-vous pour 1 raison simple,
au regard de mes engagements politiques,
au regard également de mon passif professionnel,
puisque j'ai moi-même durant 5 ans,
euh fondé 1 entreprise,
diriger 1 entreprise
qui s'avère être 1 école supérieure
qui existe depuis 1 temps,
plus de 6 ans,
donc je connais le quotidien, euh.
Administratif, réglementaire,
fiscale, et. Et.
Et le coup du travail, pour l'avoir subi aussi
directement maintenant.
Alors j'ai cru
comprendre que cette déclaration allait régire
pour l'avenir
mes relations avec le médef,
et je crains que
ne soit peut-être pas très bonne, puisque,
en l'occurrence,
l'un des sujets aussi
majeurs d'engagement dans cette campagne,
c'est aussi, euh.
La question de l'immigration.
Voilà, je vais pas vous surprendre
et je pense que il faut mesurer aujourd'hui que
voir recourir
facilement et
systématiquement à l'immigration
pour palier à nos défaillances.
Économiques n'est pas la bonne solution.
Regarde, j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure,
du taux d'inactivité en France et du taux de chômage,
mais surtout
regarde des conséquences sur le moyen long terme,
extrêmement grave sur notre société.
Le changement de d'identité,
le changement culturel,
les conséquences securitaires et que,
imaginez que cela n'a pas 1 impact sur l'économie
et selon moi, 1 erreur majeure,
parce que ce coup de l'immigration,
il se paye, il se paye sur la fiscalité,
il se paye sur les dépenses sociales,
il se paye dans les dépenses
liées justement à l'augmentation de l'insécurité.
Combien d'entreprise ici, sages,
euh, ce que cela coûte de mettre des digicotes,
des alarmes, de changer euh. Le rideau de fer à l'entrée ?
Parce que évidemment, nous sommes face,
euh à à de graves conséquences aujourd'hui
de l'immigration sur notre société.
Donc je n'en changerai pas de ce point de vue.
Défendre les entreprises,
oui, mais défendre notre identité en priorité également.
Merci Marion maréchal.